[Musique]
robin
oui
oui moi
m
ou pas
wae
ah ah
et
[Musique]
merci merci beaucoup souray d'abord
remercier tous ceux qui ont voté pour
moi j'ai rien préparé je m'attendais pas
un 7 d'or franchement on a beau dire ça
fait plaisir
mais aussi remercier toute l'équipe sans
qui je ne serais pas là ce soir
excusez-moi si j'en oublie je vais
profiter d'être là pour vous dire que
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche c'est
votre artichauts bien au chaud du samedi
soir bonsoir dans la série dinosaures
fameux hormis ce dinosaure record en
voici les temptations en direct du
paradis selon gordy berry pour les
intimes des riches heures de la tamla
les temptations
[Musique]
mamma mia
à
qui moi
mais
comme dit
[Musique]
jacques
non
la timone
[Musique]
m
au mois de mai
[Musique]
après les jo la série noire continue
avec isaac de bankolé et avant black box
interview antilles est no
différentialiste mais sans prise de tête
ses lunettes alors il est comment on
peut faire l'amour avec un [__] sans se
fatiguer il faut le laisser faire
[Musique]
il marche moyennement stella il ya eu
c'est pas un genre de roger comme ça un
peu de la paresse en général faut dire
que bon c'est y truquer un peu osé ouais
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça j'ai fait le
film ouais enfin c'est le titre d'abord
que j'ai entendu qui m'a qui a retenu
mon attention et puis après j'ai
rencontré le mec qui a fait le bouquin
avait rien laferrière et d un mec
adorable donc on a essayé de monter
l'opération deux ans après le film s'est
fait et pour moi si tu veux
le plus important c'était que ce film
existe c'est l'histoire de deux mecs qui
vivent dans un quartier de montréal et
il y en a un qui se prend peuvent pour l
écrivain d'encaisser l'écrire à ses
fantasmes c'est le personnage que fait
et puis l'autre c'est un personnage qui
celui qui reste allongé il pratique la
drague et mobiles
c'est-à-dire qu'il y ferait aide le
corps à le caser un peu il donne des
conseils c'est 55 sur la sexualité
laisse moins de
temps je vais t'expliquer
écoute supposons que voici l'année
gallas est d'accord pardon la blanche
genève et le blanc
dans l'échelle de valeurs occidentales
la blanche antérieure au plan supérieur
aux [__]
d'accord
c'est avec moi qu'il faut être d'accord
ou pas tu penses que j'aime ça moi est
trop bas de l'échelle
et aucune visite dite d'accord croissant
des croissants donc la blanche étant
inférieur aux blancs mais il n'y a
qu'avec le [__] quelque part son pied
[Musique]
c'est pas sorcier
havelange me faire rire le blanc mais
ces [__] qui fait fuir la blanche avec
lui et le but aller jusqu'au bout
selon ta place dans l'échelle de la
société où le mythe du [__] ans déjà
il a dégraissé qui l'a fait jouer
justement en personne les taux bas de
l'échelle loi à la fois faire juive et
le nèg et le blanc
parce que tu viens de dire
negri bien suite on dit toujours les
hommes préfèrent les blondes est ce que
les blondes préfère les noirs il faut
demander aux blancs bien savoir quelque
chose quand même non mais je pense que
c'est comme tout phénomène de contraste
il ya une attirance ces collisions
visitons
les dégâts ton c'est une satire est donc
c'est peut-être les choses comme ça mais
je pense plus que ces cds mitzach limite
du cliché du cliché aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que moi j'adore les italiens qui
sont beaucoup plus près
l'hymne officiel à l'origine ou de fans
dans ta vie c'est celle à qui tu es fait
deux enfants est une styliste et puis on
a fait deux enfants est
d'accord ah oui
c'est une styliste une styliste belge
rêve c'est y vit à bruxelles elle vit à
quelques kilomètres de bruxelles c'est
ma compagne depuis une dizaine d'années
oui il à faire idéal du moi
disons que je suis l été qui croient aux
gens de prendre les gens portent la
tension est forte de l'amour c'est une
fille que j'ai rencontrés quand je
travaillais dans un arbre il ya des
lenteurs des lombards et tête et
plongeurs oui quand je des plongeurs et
on s'entend très bien
je pense que ça durera encore mais quand
tu vas chez chopin chez tes parents
abidjan en côte d'ivoire comment est ce
que ta famille reçoit le fait que
débarque là bas avec une blanche se la
poser aussi des problèmes n'ont
peut-être plus disons que c'est vrai que
de mon côté c'était y avait plus de
problèmes que de son côté
c'est là-bas que c'est le plus dur oui
là-bas c'est très dur il faut dire que
ma mère n'étant pas les traits wade donc
elle est encore plus dense ans
commerçante et parents paysans
commerçants et il ya certaines choses
qu'elle a du mal à comprendre
non le fait d'avoir deux enfants je
crois que seul un mollet n'ont cessé que
il faut qu'elle soit et c'est
convertisse à l'islam alors on t'a vu
touré était dans toute la presse à cause
du film de gérard oury oui
c'est une très bonne idée en plus
j'aimerais bien avoir le compte de stars
le compte en banque de stages avec
sabine azéma ça va être formidable non
mais c'est vrai que le projet de gérard
c'était un projet magnifique parce que
c'était vraiment d'abord au départ le
projet a été proposé à michel et 2,9 et
chercher une amie et chênes blancs
michel blanc
s'impose
alors et pourquoi pas la preuve c'est
que j'ai fait le film on savait très
très très bien entendu et je crois que
ce serait être très confus quand on dit
de toi que tu es le eddie murphy
français ça te fait quoi
à ton avis
c'est flatteur oui pour moi ah ben non
pourquoi parce que j'aimerais bien que
qui est les journalistes qui puisse dire
à eddie murphy qui les
examinera de son côté en fait c'est un
oui j'ai mis deux parce que ça me
plaisait je remet ça de rajouter les
c'est comme ça c'est comme princess
erika oui pour se recueillir il y en a
qui s'est implantée à l'idée blanc
saveur un peu maintenant ça va danser
rires ouais c'est pas un plan frime
c'est un plan plus tôt pour voir un peu
où on était sept sociétés occidentales
danser dans ses rapports avec les
colonies mais moi ça me plaisait bien
alors tu aimes pas quand on dit blake
toi parce que tu dis que c'est une façon
je crois que blake c st- terme usité son
terme importés des états unis je crois
c'est une façon de masquer les choses
c'est pas juste apporter un petit jeu
par hasard
moi j'apporte un extrait d'une
définition du mot [__]
qui était dans un dictionnaire
le petit larousse édition 1886 et la
définition qu il donne ses hommes femmes
à peau noire c'est le nom donné
spécialement aux habitants de certaines
contrées de l'afrique de la guinée la
sénégambie etc qui forment une race
d'hommes noirs inférieur à
l'intelligence à la race france vite
race caucasienne la coloration de la
peau paraît être dû chez les [__] l
influence du climat c'est une
modification acquise qui devient
transmissibles est héréditaire mais il
est généralement reconnu qu'une femme il
est transplanté dans un climat dans
notre climat arrivera à la couleur
blanche après quelques générations et
s'emmêlant fleurance tu vois un incendie
rebonds c'est insensé
ça n'a pas de longtemps il ya un peu
plus d'un siècle ouais et c'est vrai que
je préfère aujourd'hui le mot [__] ça
tout dépend de comment c'est utilisé
dans quel contexte dans quelle situation
si c'est une façon sympathique tu peux
faire mais oui je préférais être parce
que même des gens comme aimé césaire des
gens comme le
chantre de la négritude et je vois pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui on est francophone
et il ya des mots qui existent pour
appeler les races je vois pas pourquoi
on va aller chercher des mois américain
je n'ai rien contre eux alors quand je
me retrouve aux états unis je dirais
blacks je suis en france je me ferme
avec et cette mode des neiges good par
exemple tu en penses quoi tout ça vers
le 14 juillet avec des blagues tissu
mesh l'axé c'est bien un moment je veux
dire comme
comme tout mode ya une fin et il faut
pouvoir aller au delà de la mort par
exemple si tu rentres carlton en 88
quand était à cannes pour pour chocolat
et que le mec il ya du baston à l'entrée
turrel j comment c'est le manuscrit ou c
ou c'est la haine c'est même pas la
haine c'est une sorte de déception de
déception d'une civilisation d'une
société qui m'a apprise des choses qui a
plus de choses à ma race à ma culture
bon je suis héréditaires comme ça et de
voir que en fait j'ai été berné en fait
j'ai été berné par des gens qui ne sont
pas et même fort à l'intérieur et
aujourd'hui quand on n'est pas fort à
l'intérieur je crois qu'on est appelé à
disparaître
oui on devient agressif et je crois
qu'il faut pas répondre par
l'agressivité parce que moi je les fais
il ya 15 ans quand j'étais à paris mais
ça n'a pas résolu les problèmes les
noirs ni ni même mes problèmes et je
crois qu'il faut passer outre sa et
c'est bizarre parce que tu ne parles de
la mode c'est vrai que quand je marche
dans paris on se montrait des pubs et
qui donc personne n'en parle ne parle
que les plus matures qu'on lance
benetton
il y en a une en particulier qu'il
faille et noir qui allaitent avec les
bleus et blancs donc on ne voit pas le
visage de la femme je trouve que c'est
carrément abjecte comme comme publicité
je veux dire
c'est indécent c'est indécent c'est même
pas digne de ces sociétés là tu vas
retourner un jour là bas c'est un c'est
une utopie ouais dire l'idée du retour
et quelque chose je crois qui a
longtemps fait défaut en tout cas fait
beaucoup de mal la communauté noire
africaine qui s'expatrient qui est venu
en europe puisque tout le temps les gens
même quand ils veulent et voulait pas se
l'avouer si tu es il se disait qu'ils
vont rentrer qui vont rentrer ce qui
fait qu'il ne pouvait pas vivre notre
convenablement là où il était et je
crois que c'est un danger de vouloir à
tout prix rentrer il faudrait bien là où
on est c'est tout
moi je suis une négropolitain
c'est le mot il ya des [__] africain
il ya des [__] américain
moi je suis négropolitain 3 qui a quitté
la tête de son hit parade et ils jouent
à reconnaître les premiers du top 50 au
blind test attire retourné sa veste yens
julien dray julien dray bonsoir député
ps de l'essonne et pieds-noirs oui les
revenus en 65 pourquoi pendant 62 parce
que entre 62 et 65 mes parents sont
restés en algérie
je suis resté à l'école croyez qu'il
pouvait rester il pense à l'époque
pouvaient rester et pourquoi ils sont
pas restés parce qu'il ya eu des débuts
de pousser en type d'antenne
antisémitisme et à ce moment là en
algérie et donc ont préféré rentrer en
france quand tu étais à la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire de d'alain
krivine est ce qui était arrivé dans les
années 60 de défiler bras dessus bras
dessous avec michel rocard
pas bras dessus bras dessous parce que
j'étais pas j'étais un militant de base
et dirigeants étaient en tête les
mutants pas été derrière les clés dans
les mêmes défiler comme invité dans les
mains de j au psu et vous la lcr voilà
devait même fiche jaunie pour faire une
grande remise à vue
et quand tu le rencontres aujourd'hui
dans son bureau on dit dans le même
parti
ça crée des liens où ils se trouvent
voit par exemple
il vous voit vous voit camarades on voit
monsieur walsh aux députés
après tu étais vice président de l'unef
id rythme infondées sos racisme tu as un
peu bon le poil à gratter du ps le
trouble fête le trouble consensus
pendant la grève des infirmières ont
appelé le baron noir c'est à dire on
supposer que c'était toi comme ça qui a
attisé le feu et c'est peut-être pas
complètement forum un nom il s'est
trouvé que au moment où la grève des
infirmières a commencé j'ai été un des
premiers députés à dire que je pensais
qu'elle avait raison descendent dans la
rue j'ai passées comme elles gagnent les
infirmières elles gagnent environ 6000
francs par bon voilà donc demandé à
l'époque 2000 francs en augmentation et
puis elle était prête à étaler dans le
temps je ne pense pas vu le métier
qu'elles font que c'était au ridicule
donc j'ai dit cela et puis un bon comme
j'étais un des seuls qui le disait dans
le groupe parlementaire socialiste à ce
moment là bas elle est devenue marron
voilà et ben voilà alors à ce moment là
tu as été convoqué plus ou moins dix ans
à matignon dans le bureau de monsieur
huchon et tu as retrouvé sur le bureau
de semences une conversation
téléphonique que tu avais eue avec l'ats
la cheffe de la coordination des
infirmières donc on avait écouté donc et
non moi j'ai pas été convoqués c'est des
journalistes les relations avec époque
matignon effectivement à qui on a donné
un certain nombre de détails qui
montrait que des informations avaient
été transmises avaient été écoutés
j'ai laissé un point d'interrogation
disons que les informations étaient
précis est ce qu'un orchestre rouge
d'anciens trop de ce quart parce qu'on
est toujours entre autres car un jour
trop de cartons journaux un sk alors
qu'un orchestre rouge l'ancien trop de
ce quartier qui comme ça cherche à
noyauter le psa à noyauter le président
boulot énorme tube 10 et des anciens
trop de cas voilà coupe ah bon et plus
trop ce carême non parce que les
trotskistes et croire à beaucoup de
choses la révolution mondiale qui va
arriver et c'est moi je crois pas tout
ça je dis à quelqu'un qui veut changer
les choses la société française qui vont
les améliorer enfin été soutenu par
tonton c'est vrai quitter a dit ce point
diffusé en feront voir de toutes les
couleurs mais vous ne changerai pas
d'idée vespa ses volte face à la 10 à 20
de mon élection il m'a dit il faut faut
affirmer sa personnalité est ce que
finalement
toi tu veux toujours refaire le monde et
puis tes amis ont fini par s'en
satisfait après c'est un peu ça le
problème de vision qu'un à qu'ils sont
fatigués vouloir refaire le point mais
est ce que tu crois vraiment qu'on peut
encore changer la vie ce que tu crois
encore à changer la vie oui comment par
exemple de moi un exemple précis
augmenter les infirmières d'accord mais
demain est un autre exemple précis par
exemple inventé une nouvelle
civilisation des villes diffèrent que
par exemple les crèches soit ouverte
plus souvent faire par exemple que les
commerces soient ouverts plus tard le
soir le devoir des problèmes la cgt et
la wii d'accord mais il faut après il
faut prendre le problème cela va
favoriser le les capitalistes qui
possède les chaînes de commerce que de
demander que ce soit ouvert le soir ou
le dimanche non il se peut aussi
améliorer la vie des gens que de faire
que par exemple tous les services de vie
convivial ouvert le plus tard possible
et puis ça peut créer des emplois à
l'arrivée je pense pas que les gens si
le dimanche en plus ils vont faire des
courses alors qu'ils sont déjà bouffé
par la société marchande je pense pas
que c'est emmerdant non je suis pas de
ces gens qui pendant à ça que le
dimanche est réservé aujourd'hui
seigneur quand tes parents sont partis
d'algérie c'était à cause d'une poussée
d'antisémitisme est aujourd'hui en
france on peut pas dire que ce soit
franchement l' inverse
je suis pas parano
je pense que les juifs sont destinés à
tous veulent être les persécutés
l'histoire mais c'est vrai que ça peut
recommencer dans des périodes difficiles
c'est un bon exutoire le jeu c'est plus
la rame en ce moment c'est l'arabe et le
juif ça en faire beaucoup plus quand est
arrivée en france tu habitais ou à rosny
sous bois c'était dur comme à l'époque
non ce n'est pas dur dur c'était
mais dans ces années là t'as pas eu
envie d'aller s'installer en israël par
exemple
jamais j'étais français j'ai jamais
pensé que j'ai d'un autre pays que la
france vous ne savez jamais très bien ce
qu'ils écoutent et quoique musicale et
pavie moi j'étais très fière j'étais
très à bord récente
transistors comme celui des grands le
tpr et pour le blind test alors on va
l'essayer quoi je suis traumatisé partie
automne
bravo à vous
suivre
[Musique]
l'année
viendra
c'est pascal danel way
dans cette son pays ça c'est que j'ai
mis
tellement avait promis d' aimer mais
quand on accepte un mois marché mais
d'autres ont déçu que moi moi je n'aime
pas les cambrioleurs et dans un
procès ça c'est un groupe de pieds noirs
qui fait managée par un curé
bon allure
c'est les missiles un sacré dollars eh
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si le soir descente enfin des parties 7
pour faire ça ils sont bloqués
l'oratoire blessés
quand les fêtes s'achève rigolez pas ça
gêne pas très branché dans les boutiques
jacob
moi je reviendrai pas
derrière connie toi ouais parce qu on se
fait bouger la tête à la radio
chaque
fois qu'on peut aimer aussi les mec qui
chante à bois ou
oh
atelier du monde début de soirée
il y aura tout faire oui ça c'est
dominique cantien vous
voilà
l'australien voici agnès soral qui
renvoie bien les balles il ya déjà une
légende agnès soral tu cesseras quand
même non je n'ai pas tu avais 14 ans et
habiter sur le palier de thierry la
fronde enfin c'était son ton voisin
djallit et disant tu habitais passe dans
son palais ah bon mais c'est vrai cette
histoire est celle d'autrui bon quand on
raconte les fonds normaux
mais c'est vrai j'ai vu passer tirer la
fronde avec un pantalon je me suis fait
un nul enfin pour thierry la fronde
jones en temps et donc je vais demander
ou est ce qu'il avait mis sa fronde sa
titulaire à dorel petit côté de soi
c'est très sexy voilà que le prendre je
sais j'avais 4 ans donc ça m'a rappelé
un peu quand j'étais bébé et quand tu
l'as vu tu as décidé de faire du cinéma
j'ai appris j'ai j'ai dis toujours c'est
c'est parti d'un quiproquo je pensais
que je joue et ça voulait dire s'amuser
moyenne plaisanterie mais
mais c'est mais aussi au fond
j'ai découvert qu'on pouvait faire un
métier c'était simplement dit qu'on peut
prendre la personnalité des genres se
cacher derrière un personnage trouve ça
pas mal depuis que tu fais du cinéma tu
as déjà rencontré une personnalité que
tu aurais voulu garder et je te la fais
chancel tu vois là
c'est une question est ce que je cherche
c'est ça non mais c'est intéressant
c'est vrai que parfois ce que des fois
tu t'es dit je voudrais rester c'est
cette fille là où ce mec là c'est trop
suffisamment de rôle conséquent et de
composition pour pouvoir penser ça mais
c'est vrai que il ya des personnages qui
m'ont aidé à développer une certaine de
l'agressivité par exemple c'est surtout
pendant un moment je j'ai vu la vie
différemment et renault sport on est
enfin moi j'ai des fois je sais j'ose
pas est négatif je me dis
alors après tu es venu à paris tu as eu
deux ans de galère alors après 15 ans je
vois les gens galèrent
tu sais quoi tu suivais comment tu es ce
que tu est rester digne dans la pauvreté
j'ai revu le projet des ménages
la france entière club j'ai gardé des
enfants g
ben on fait le ménage est fait dédé et
prêt-à-porter en dansant
ga
à revendre idée
sous prétexte que ça avait vaguement
la peintre que maintenant c'était pas le
même quoi
mettre un petit dorures certes au point
séparé pendant sa alors après les vifs
celle épingle pour tout préparer à thon
rouge
où il ya des gens qui disent que j'ai vu
six mois en fait je suis passé
pas tellement parce que bon après une
descente de fink après une descente de
rock tous à 100 de poudre une descente
j avais la réalité dépasse et un peu la
fiction donc
c'était un peu dur de dormir habillée
avec
petit bar près de 100 le dit ces
terrasses étaient c'était sympa mais
enfin des fois c'était du style tu te
balades avec quelqu'un de sympa et d'un
seul coup tu te retourne pour regarder
quelque chose tu entends un bris de
vitrines brisées et c'est l'autre qui a
juste vu un super amusant
d'en tracer une voiture et tu te
retrouves à courir avec une sirène alors
que est en train de détente était bien
dans ce film ouais le film était bien
c'est facile d'être bien dans un monde
là je veux dire tu as une réputation
quand même dans le métier faudra me dire
c'est de faire sérieusement le service
après-vente moi j'aimerais préparer la
promo mais vraiment sérieusement communs
comme la promo sérieusement mâchouillée
territoire qui s'appelle australia avec
jeremy iron fanny ardant et du carillon
et c'est l'histoire d'une passion
moi je les ai vus mais dis moi par
exemple si tu devais m'en voyez le voir
qu'est ce que tu dirais
jusqu'à répéter ta promo donc tu sais
exactement où s'achève avant ça non
doucement vers l e10 dont tu vas trouver
comment
bombay toi vraiment
très bien s'est alors dit moi avant le
mois ce film il faut que je me foutais
là pour ça bon il faut et je faisais
mais fanny ardant et alors maintenant il
ya les pour et les contre fanny ardant
sais quelle réplique on ne peut pas
laisser indifférent et puis à durer mais
gijon qui est quand même un acteur
qui a fait ses preuves en mai shon
et dans sa pleine et joue un peu dans ce
soit nos 6 et les puis bon tchéky karyo
je pense que c'est un omeyer
c'est sympa que développe enfin
oui d'ailleurs ça fait un peu c'est sale
et électrices qui vient d'appeler
non je vais me taire m'a parlé d'autres
chiens et chats ça va mais ça
on a repris 2 km
je me demande qui peut bien rester de
verviers toile chez quelqu'un qui est
parti vingt ans
à vrai dire pas grand chose je connais
des tas d'histoires sur
vous voulez je vous en raconte
oh
vous avez d'autres sujets de
conversation avait choqué mais qui vous
dit que c'est lui
oh
non
de toute façon en un formateur se fait
un peu rapace il y en a que pour vous
pourtant chine
oh
[Musique]
vous savez que vous observe non vraiment
oh
mais déjà je me
bon
un bon horoscope aujourd'hui il y avait
marqué rencontre agréable dans la soirée
je le souhaite
tu vas voir page 2 alors on va faire
l'interview we know they presse
es tu ne pouvais
kieffer
est ce que tu penses tu réponds que par
oui ou par non
est ce que tu penses est ce que tu
penses que tu mérites ce qui t'arrive
non d'accord est ce que tu penses que ça
va durer
plantant oui est ce que si le scénariste
c'était vraiment intelligente
dufresne par nos soins
[Musique]
est-ce que tu éteins la lumière avant de
finalement ah bon tu l'as lu monsieur
l'état
[Musique]
oui est ce que tu es arrivé de faire
l'amour hier que dans un lit
[Musique]
dubai world is our inspiration
oui
est-ce que c'était arrivé d'avoir le
coup de foudre pour que ça passe et que
ça devienne sexuelles dans les cinq
minutes qui suivent je me renseigne ses
portes
une femme
oui là oui oui c'est personnel torre ont
de suite été surprise par ton maka qui
montre les
images y faire ça sur le service public
c'est ce que je veux dire
moi
non ouattara
ça me libérer
c'était arrivé la même
bon ce dernière question est-ce que tu
thème oui non
alors tout un dernier oui ni non
lorsqu'on vend tutelle ou pas
à
la tête
tout ce qui vient du rss et béni oui oui
surtout aux états unis voici donc boris
grebennikov leur coeur joker superstar
du plan quinquennal du gorbatchev
nationale chef leur produit par dave
stewart voici l'enjeu l'affairé strict à
god bless soviétique
m
demain
non
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
j'avais
bats toi
[Musique]
madame irma
ça va
m
non
je suis
[Applaudissements]
bracke ne peuvent c'était des reines
shicoff culture mais pas culture c'est
la recette de ta planète malus m voici
donc on off pinacle au pilon en est du
lot en brûle si luca en question gaston
hot spots au ronald chez albin michel
pour switchback bio 600 pages consacré
aux monstres secret où l'on découvre
qu'alfred été aussi cochon qu'il en
avait l'air
christopher frank je ferai comme si je
n'étais pas là au seuil quand on
s'appelle franck quand les cinéastes
c'est dur de se faire un prénom dans la
littérature
anne wiazemsky mon beau navire chez
gallimard comme quoi on peut être la
petite fille de mauriac l'ex-femme de
godard et avoir du talent à revendre
super hunt si c'est possible à la bonne
en feu mon histoire d'amour chez grasset
c'est écrit comme on aime aucun prix en
vue donc le livre de la rentrée banane
d'or de la semaine
or pascal guignard les escaliers de
chambord gallimard en juillet il était
sûr d'avoir le bon cours depuis on a lu
le livre précieux et ridicule tatane de
respect
pierre jean rémy pour toscane chez alba
bien sûr c'est mieux que d'habitude
c'est presque own mais de là à crier ou
venise demorand il ya un pas que je ne
franchirais pas voyez vous c'était une
ctf la semaine prochaine les expos il y
en a un qui a toutes les chances d'être
fun c'est ben ben vautier et sur l'une
est bien au chaud sous la couette caylar
michaud alors benjamin vautier alias ben
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
tu es arrivé à nice en 49 qui ont été
d'abord libraires qui après tu as été
brocanteurs et avait un magasin de
disques qui était très célèbre système
exorbitants que je faisais des expos et
donc vous m'ont donné et puis j'ai
essayé de montrer ce qu'il y avait de
nouveau dans le meck ce magasin de
disques un jour il a été exposé à
beaucoup enfin maintenant il est exposé
à vous hisser pontus qui a trouvé que
c'était une belle oeuvre et puis moi
même aussi bassiste et d'un magasin 10
dans lequel je t'ai rien je connais tous
remués parce qu'il y avait eu marcel
duchamp il ya eu le nouveau réalisme et
donc je voulais faire une oeuvre d'art
en touchant avait dit tout est art et
toi tu dis une fois qu'il ya eu touchant
tout est périmée heureusement au tout et
à jeudi que les agents sont des gens il
nous amène dans une situation
désespérée dans la mesure où les chants
expose un point douter et donc tout est
possible
impossible de faire du land art du bourg
à dupont pas le nouveau réalisme tout
est dans tout et perrier j'avance et si
on la met dans l'intérim d'avant c'est à
dire que c'est d'accepter d'avant donc
mais plus choquant mais manger toujours
plus que en art qu'il fallait apporter
quelque chose c'est à dire un avis qui
veut le produit est moins intéressant
que l'artiste qui apporte donc il faut
apporter quelque chose donc toute ma
première partie ma période ça a été une
année de apporter du nouveau cirque
bidon que j'ai cherché du nouveau je
m'étais dit personne a fait des coups de
pied au cul donc je veux qu'ils écoutent
et aux qpc n'est signé le manque donc le
signe et le membre d'un sauna fait ceci
est donc ça c'est être dans les années
cinquante huit où j'ai méthodiquement
cherché à faire ce qui n'avait pas été
fait puisque je m'étais dit l'histoire
de la cecc une histoire des choses qu'on
fait pas donc un jour tu t'es dit bon je
sais pas klein il a fait le bleu moi je
vais faire les textes par exemple ça
c'était l'époque c'était très simple et
ex si tu veux savoir un jour on m'a
demandé d une exposition de goût et je
suis allé voir sur les autres exposés je
suis moi je voudrais qu'on le garde mon
tableau jekyll le garder moi s'il vous
plaît ne regardez pas les autres alors
ensuite s'il dit comme ça et le gade et
après je me suis dit je veux dire la
vérité parce que quand tu le gardes un
rembrandt ou quand tu regardes un petit
génie derrière laurent blanc si tu
grattes un peu il y a un ego ya un grand
blond qui regardaient mois-ci vous
feront blanc regardez moi qu'on tirait
le garder moi moche qu'elle le garde est
mort boys donc tous l'histoire de là
c'est une histoire de goût de deux mois
qui crient à demander le garder ce que
j'ai découvert de nouveaux des restes a
été par exemple c'est non mais dont je
m'intéressais à la vérité tu vois jeune
homme de vérité où j'essaye de la vérité
parce qu'il ya des poésies pas donc y
aller vérité subjective je suis jaloux
de buzz je suis jaloux de boltanski je
vous écrivais ça donc je dis en tant
qu'artiste c'est un échec par exemple
admettons oui je pourrais écrire cij a
une angoisse j'écrivais mes angoisses ou
alors j'écrivais les vérités objectives
qui sont par exemple sur une toile de 45
cm de long tu écris ces toilettes quand
cinq centimètres de long ou tchéquie et
les noirs donc là il peut pas tuer le
contraire 1 ici ils peuvent pas dire
ouais mais des blanches quand tu dis
elle est noire et c'est simple donc
ramener les choses à leur plus communs
du simple dénominateur commun font
manquer l'école tu vas tu écrivais par
exemple je peins pour la gloire parce
que c'était vrai ouais bien sûr parce
que c'était vrai mais maintenant la
gorge en sus le menu j'ai pas que j'aie
la loi mijo j'ai un problème de bois qui
me gêne je n'écrirai plus jamais vouloir
priver pendant que vous regardez le
temps passe pas oui ça c'est vrai c'est
une vérité subjective
au début des années 60 e et r d tu as
participé à la création du mouvement
fluxus avec nam zhu pets qu'on a reçus
avec les hauts fourneaux avec john tate
bien sûr on sait quoi fluxus parce qu'on
a dit fluxus fluxus et dada plus du
vaudeville c'est vrai ça sais tu qui
connaît un peu c'est pas que tu as fait
ça c'est fluxus tu vas du champ ils font
le port de bouc et ouais mais dans une
exposition d'un il le signe le suspens
le pôle bouteille le mais la caf doit
aimer les bouteilles dessus la
différence entre fluxys et du chant
c'est que le processus et c'est de faire
rejoindre la vie dans la ménagerie c'est
une échec parce qu'il n'arrive pas à se
débarrasser de leur écot ouais donc sont
tous là avec le lego et quand john kane
ch'tis tout est musique c'est pas vrai
du tout et john cage réalité main et
qu'on ajoute des coups quand les gens
plus bien sûr sur scène et boire un
verre d'eau ils essaient de nous faire
croire que la vie est à mais c'est pas
vrai il nous faut en fait quoi que un
ippon de la revit les cantons rpt et de
compte la de comptes de réaliser à
transmettre l'art dans la vie c'est
impossible mais quand tu risques et à
l'ego qui est toujours là lire six mois
qu'il est fait avant goût et à ce moment
là c'est de là je comprends pourquoi ton
canard ça fait pas mal quand même
pourquoi parce que je suis bavard un peu
assez bien non non c'est quelque chose
que tu expliques des trucs qui pour les
gens l'air sous grenu inepte et en fait
tout ça est fait avec des vraies raisons
oui c'est vrai alors il ya un
échafaudage théorique solide c'est pas
de la fausse nouveauté dans le milieu où
n'importe quoi n'importe comment
n'importe où malgré que n'importe quoi
n'importe comment n'importe où peut être
mais le bouddha à une condition c'est
qu'on l'a su théoriquement faut savoir
où on met ses pieds
les gens devaient donner une définition
de toit par exemple tu as dit je suis le
plus grand mauvais peintre tu vois que
c'est bien ça non ben moi j'aime
beaucoup le jacques lizène qui disait
qu'il voulait être un petit mètre du
xxème siècle raté mais parce que je
trouve que les ratings pour les
réhabiliter ou si
c'est vrai que dans le mien oui chez
daltonien c'est pour ça que tu as pas
fait de la championne régionale thoniers
ne l'ont pas du tout j'ai cogné
d'intelligent bon ben je te vois noir
bon mais ça va qu'ils aient droit aurier
désir est daltonien défaut d'un thonier
les demies daltoniens je dois être demi
d'enseignants je vois pas les marrons
les bleus les mâles et mais j'ai changé
important saison et l'histoire du bourg
ne compte plus ses histoires du procès
soit de nouveau l'histoire la créativité
d'un rembrandt et mathis quand ils sont
arrivés c'était nouveau oui quand
blanche l'astuce de la lumière mathis la
suisse des ciseaux chacun son astuce
espoirs de l'enseigné l'histoire d'un
mec qui trouvent des idées à chaque fois
quoi toujours alors maintenant dire en
chasse et bruce est très bon c'est pas
vrai c'est toujours eux étaient des
types qui rompt avec quelque chose à
dire qu'ils ont découvert quelque chose
de nouveau à dire seulement il faut se
rappeler que tout ça c'est le pouvoir
qui aiment se regarder dans un miroir
c'est à dire que signé ton départ on
paie une bonne femme avec un bébé dans
les bras c'est parce que les papilles
tôt que moi si aujourd'hui on peint du
coca cola c'est parce que coca cola de
bois donc j'ai dit toujours que là c'est
exactement ce que le pouvoir veut qui se
peignent son propre reflet hélas ce
moment là on peut commencer à réfléchir
cela et je voudrais que les artistes
deviennent intelligents le nid leçon
série qui réfléchissent à ce qu'il sent
comment ils sont aujourd'hui avec le
bicentenaire en les manipuler l'histoire
de la vienne mayonnaise c'est bien des
produits qu'on fait monter en d1 à
quelque chose qui sonne faux dans le
monde là ça sert à quoi là
ça je me suis demandé là je te le dire
moi j'ai pensé un moment donné à une
histoire de bien être mais j'y crois pas
je croise ça m'angoisse puisque l'eau
chaude à cause de l'âge dans le monde de
la nuit qui donne mais mieux ce serait
mieux
mais j'arrive pas abandonner la septième
saison
tu
en v'la du slow en velin et du bon
croyez-moi hispanique tape de l'amérique
mais ça lui suffit pas elle veut mériter
son prénom gloria loria et stéphane du
dance
[Musique]
un open bar
michaud
[Musique]
de rares
sans opinion
six mois
[Musique]
passé
machaie
quand
à
ah ah
le
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui non
[Musique]
jouer
ballon est de tête
qui l'avons
et booster
et thomas petit
[Musique]
caire
que ses copines
moi je
la dent
non
oh
mais quand
oui
à
volley
[Musique]
et stéphane on est fans s'étaient gloria
estefan à don't want to lose you up vous
et voici daniel rondeau l'athlétique
andy du mal la critique en vue du bien
et il nous offre ils répondent en
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche c'est
sa revanche mon dimanche or daniel
rondeau quand tu étais responsable des
pages littéraires à libération tu avais
fait un grand article qui s'appelait
pourquoi écrivez-vous tu as vu 400
réponses et sur ces 400 réponses y avait
paul bowles qui t'a dit j'écris parce
que je fais encore partie du royaume des
vivants parce que je suis encore au [__]
vivre voilà étaient partis le voir à
tanger et a fait un bouquin qui
s'appelait tanger et qui a été un franc
succès drogba j'étais victime du gâtisme
de la nostalgie
or oh
la question de nostalgie je ne crois pas
je pense que j'ai été
j'ai pris d'abord c'était une surprise
c'était de retrouver bowles c'est quand
on avait commencé cette enquête pourquoi
écrivez-vous sait on avait demandé à 400
grands écrivains du monde pour les
écrivains au départ je pensais que paul
bowles et est mort quand j'avais bu un
thé au sahara j'avais vu après toi le
déluge je pensais que c'était devenu un
livre culte depuis
bertolucci est en train de tourner le
film en question donc d'une part c'est
une vraie surprise c'était de découvrir
un écrivain non seulement
yvan mais plutôt heureux de vivre qui
continuaient de travailler qui mène une
vie tout à fait à part dans cette ville
étrange de tanger et puis d'autre part
je pense aussi que c'est fait c'était
pour moi le plaisir
le plaisir de s'évader c'est un moyen
d'aller voir un peu ailleurs ce qui se
passait tu as été mao oui bien sûr
qu'elle est teinté tablir en usine oui
j'ai passé trois ans en usine c'était os
en valeur la wattine tu sais tout ab je
sais tout oui non parce que ça me
passionne puis maintenant tu es plutôt
gauche caviar avec l'éditeur cosmopolite
raffinée haut de gamme ou jusqu'à bien
ça me paraît
ça me paraît chez mais je suis éditeur
journaliste de l'action de la gauche
caviar mais avec les imbéciles qui ne
changent pas d'avis et puis comme ça ça
te fais pleins d'expérience mais en fait
ce qu'il n'y a pas une part de
renonciation même de reniement
maintenant
puis sa commande
j'ai pas quand tu croises des ouvriers
qui vont bosser comme toi aller bosser à
maxéville ou à pomper le matin comme ça
tu
tu es rencontres vont en usine tu penses
quoi
je ne pars je suis retourné les voir
jouer sur mes enthousiasmes je suis
retourné les voir là
non eux
j'ai retrouvé mes
de type avec qui je travaillais comme
les anciens copains de le chantier je me
suis trouvé immédiatement
de plain pied avec ce j'ai rencontré
c'est à dire on a repris une
conversation c'était avec avait été
interrompue qu'un an auparavant je n'ai
pas le sentiment d'avoir
vous avoir péri les avoir trahis ni
d'avoir changé voilà tu publié un
bouquin chez chez grasset en fait un
premier gros roman c'est combien de
pages pour faire toutes mes 400 pages
beaucoup travaillé j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir à travailler alors cette
histoire c'est un jeune bourgeois qui
par désoeuvrement par nostalgie par
amour devient terroristes d'où sa vie
comme ça et puis après on le retrouve
rangé des voitures colombophilie le père
de famille créateur d'une pme toi
finalement
rangé des voitures et enfoncé aussi
simple que c'est un peu simple je pense
que
non seulement il est rangé des voitures
mais il s'est enfoncé quand même dans le
lait brisé oui il est brisé si ce n est
brisée s'est enfoncé dans le l'anonymat
avec orgueil avec délectation streep est
il est en plein d'expier
ces fautes
je veux pas tellement de ressemblance
entre lui et moi d'abord
alors bon il ya eu des critiques
terribles sur le style et c'est vrai que
quand on quand on lis ton bouquin par
rapport à tanger par rapport à l'
enthousiasme quand on sait que tu aimes
bien des gens comme mort en disant c'est
plutôt l'inversé ça il ya eu il ya eu
d'énormes critiques sur le style et on
peut se dire un moment que tu un peu
confondu tu as cru que bien écrire et
décrire bien ça sent un peu le
non
je peux pas vivre à chacun d'apprécier
le livre moi je peux dire une seule
chose c'est que
j'ai la faiblesse de biens industriels
eux il ya eu des critiques
effectivement
une des bonnes et des mauvaises on va y
venir et enfin par exemple dans les
mauvaises et rinaldi qui cite des
phrases l'inquiétude qui agite et les
fourreaux y voir un de ses doigts lui ça
le
ca le démonte ça ou de sa nuque blonde
jusqu'au marbre bal de ces crises enfin
ce genre de phrase beaucoup de critiques
en sortie des phrases en fait c'est pas
tellement le fond du gouverneur et
attaquer
personne n'attaque le fond en attaque
dans les papiers qui a eu en attaque le
la voiture trouver l'air chaud c'est
claire devarrieux dans l'est dis tu as
raté une marche dit même que c'est nul
je pense que c'est que ce genre de truc
qui est bien sorti je ne pense pas que
je pense que les critiques font mal leur
travail je ne pense pas que le travail
avec les cliques se fait de sortir
quelques phrases ne l'écouté de leurs
contacts pour essayer de riz qu'il
devient ridicule izel 400 pages je
marche pense pas que ça soit celle
écrite je ne pense pas que ce découpage
comme ça à bricoler
je ne pense pas que ça soit devrait
rester sur un faux procès je pense que
c'est un faux procès enfin par rapport à
tanger
c'est ça l'enjeu social qui étaient des
livres je pense que l'ambition lente
pour dire les choses simplement je pense
que
d'enthousiasmé et angers sont plus
proches
journalisme en tout cas sont des récits
où l'ambition est nettement moins en
moins c'est à dire que la question du
style ou des styles parce que je pense
que dans
voilà les tambours du monde j'ai essayé
d'utiliser plusieurs styles aussi donc
chaque style voulait rendre une certaine
situation en tout cas la multiplicité
des styles voulait rendre une certaine
complexité du monde on n'a pas comment
tu le disais on n'a pas parlé du fond du
livre non tous les gens qui ont descendu
livres pour pas dit un mot sur le thème
du livre sur les thèmes du livre
[Musique]
c'est a répondu non la réponse est
et j'ai livré les chiens aboient la
caravane passe est ce que tu vas tu
cherchais pas à succès grand public en
faisant un groupe bien comme ça et je
veux dire le journal elle pour sa très
bien qu'en phase du coup adore ce livre
est ce que tu cherchais pas finalement
bon c'est que c'est les femmes que chez
tes livres à faire un livre pour les
femmes
non on s'est même naturellement c'est
on ne pense pas j'ai travaillé pendant
quatre ans et comme chez lady j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à écrire danger d'en
douter ni combien de temps parc de moi
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à l'écrire
et en fait je n'étais pas pressé de même
d'arrêter de conclure ce livre c'est à
dire que
à
et on pense jamais en tout cas je n'ai
jamais pensé une seule seconde au public
dans des clivages décrivent parce que de
façon égoïste
chaque jour enfin quand j'étais à paris
cinq jours je travaillais je prenais
grand plaisir j'étais comprendre qu'on
finale
[Musique]
tu es la cible des dîners en ville ça te
fait quoi photo qui a été adoré d'un
seul coup le savoir que dans les dîners
les gens disent du mal de toi
je ne veux pas ça
la peine non ça naturellement ça ne fait
pas plaisir je parle pas des nues en
brèche par des critiques les critiques
n'ont jamais plaisir mais
je pense aussi que j'ai décidé de si
j'ai un peu je me suis reculé un peu du
journalisme c'est parce que j'avais
l'intention
décrire
je crois que j'ai le privilège de
respirer l'air que j'ai envie de
respirer
et que va être de temps en temps la
cible des dîners en ville c'est
peut-être pas payé
changement de trio à cindy t'es au
courant alternatif il passe dans
lunettes kim d lille les années sont là
ouais si des ihm d'izneo seventies ou à
lui le cheveu l'upci quel élu le cri de
la mouche à écouter avec des lunettes
[Musique]
clip sado-maso mois ci gadio l'amour
vache ça crache leur succès l'amour à
lattes soit sage denis
[Musique]
cette façon de mettre
et on s'est quitté jeudi matin
votre immense portée nécessaire par la
fenêtre de sa chambre puis jérémy cornu
6 4
j'ai l'été venir
et un belge
[Musique]
c'est
fort pèse mois
debout les damnés de la terre quand son
impur abreuve nos microsillon ils
descendent de thionville pour envahir la
ville le plus punk rock du rock punk ses
paradoxes et comme disait georges de ces
vies si vis pacem para bellum au fait
chaud chaud s'échauffent c'est une bise
sylvain bergère
[Musique]
h
sa porte
ça
les nets
en direct du palace ils espèrent même si
les lunettes de la semaine anti stress
valérie mairesse qu'aucune héroïne de
rouge venise détiennent père y est allé
ensuite mise super héros n'est pas las
folie du début de la décennie goodrich
héritan place saint thomas d'aquin grand
mais d'une fois qu'est ce que tu crois
aulas passé georgina l'infirmière de la
croix rouge
terry jones bientôt dans l'une est après
qu'ils aient guillian monty python c'est
vraiment béton mitterrand refusé de
l'inviter au sommet des droits de
l'homme le président à vie de syldavie
match cov
portes de la perception comme disait
axes les aldous ma douce james morrison
ray manzarek donne des sports robert
allan les doors
[Musique]
les autres je
je ne sais pas
efforts
et
non
je sais pas
m
j'adore
elle
comment
voulons le monde et nous le voulons
maintenant sur le leader 167 et ça
fonctionne premier 45 premiers tubes
light my fire l'amérique fait une place
au soleil au roi lézard
comment tu marques
tu me morice lac au roi du rock
orgasmique on n'avait pas vu ça depuis
elvis the pelvis on ne retrouvera cinq
avec qu'avec personnes
[Musique]
hu
cette page
à
[Musique]
oh
chef
1972 morrison annonce la fin du rêve
hippie lors de sa dernière apparition au
festival de why il déclare les
spectateurs sont des vampires tranquille
on paie par ses fans morrison s'en va
muer à paris il atterrit en 71 au père
lachaise celui des poètes
[Musique]
m
bien sûr
voilà
les
à
jeudi
m
[Musique]
on sait
tu as
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
nos repas lui batman isaac de bankolé
julien dray
agnès soral peine
[Musique]
et daniel rondeau il était dans lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches et ouais t'as
tout compris c'est fini ardisson sur la
chaîne la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
roy
ouah
et tout ça
oh
[Musique]
roja
oui
bah
pour les hommes
wade
m
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux